we're told that a large tire spins with
angular velocity 4 Omega a smaller tire
spins with half the angular velocity I'm
assuming half the angular velocity of
the large tire how does the period t sub
large of the large tire compare with the
period T sub small of the small tire so
pause this video and see if you can
figure that out and figure out which
choice you would pick ok so the key here
is to realize the connection between
angular velocity and period and instead
of just blindly memorizing a formula I
always like to reason it through a
little bit
we know that period is equal to well
think about it
in order to complete one cycle if I'm
doing uniform circular motion if I'm
going in a circle around like this in
order to do one complete lap around the
circle or a complete one cycle I have to
cover two pi radians so two pi radians
is what I need to cover and then I
divide that by my angular velocity how
fast am I going through the radians so
that's how I like to reason through this
formula that connects angular velocity
or the magnitude of angular velocity and
the period and so we can say T sub large
I'll do this in two different colors we
could say T sub large T sub large is
going to be equal to 2 pi over it says a
large tire spins with angular velocity
for Omega so it's going to be 2 pi its
angular velocity is 4 Omega so 2 PI over
4 Omega and then T sub small a smaller
tire spins with half the angular
velocity so T sub small T sub small is
going to be equal to 2 pi and it's going
to have half the angular velocity is a
large tire so that half of 4 Omega is 2
Omega so how do these two things compare
well it might be helpful to just
simplify these expressions a little bit
so T sub large the period of the large
tire is going to be PI over 2 Omega and
T sub small the period of the smaller
tire that's just going to be
hi / Omega and so the red expression
right over here is half of this blue
expression I could rewrite this as being
equal to 1/2 times 1/2 times pi / Omega
or another way of writing this I could
write T sub large T sub large is equal
to 1/2 times this expression right over
here is a period of the smaller tire so
T sub small now which of these choices
match up to that well it is this one
right over here the period of the larger
tire is going to be 1/2 the period of
the smaller tire now it's always nice if
you have the time if you know if you're
on time pressure to just think about
whether that makes sense so a large tire
spins with an angular velocity of 4
Omega the smaller tire spins with half
the angular velocity so if it has half
the angular velocity it's rotating half
as fast if it's rotating half as fast it
would take twice as long to complete one
cycle so the small tire is gonna take
twice as long or you could view it as
the large tire takes half as long as the
small tire so that makes sense let's do
another example an ice skater spins with
angular velocity 2 Omega she brings her
arms away from her body decreasing her
angular velocity 2 Omega how does the
frequency of her spin change once again
pause this video and see if you can
figure that out on your own well let's
just think about how frequency is
connected to angular velocity we already
know that period from the last question
is equal to or have to complete two pi
radians to complete a cycle and then we
could divide that by how quickly we are
how quickly our angle is increasing and
so there you have it that's our period
is 2pi over our angular velocity and if
we want frequency frequency is just the
reciprocal of period so frequency is
just going to be Omega over 2 pi this is
how many cycles we can complete in a
second and so
at first the ice skater spins with an
angular velocity of two Omega so let's
say frequency frequency let's call it
frequency initial initial is going to be
equal to her angular velocity is 2 Omega
it's going to be 2 Omega over 2 pi and
then her frequency final I'll say
frequency final so after she puts her
arms away from her body decreasing her
angular velocity and we'll talk more
about that phenomenon in the in other
videos is going to be so decreasing her
angular velocity 2 Omega
so now her angular velocity is omega and
it's going to be over 2 pi so how do
these to come out of these compare well
if I write her initial frequency I could
rewrite it as initial frequency initial
frequency is equal to 2 times Omega let
me do that another color 2 times Omega
over 2 pi write 2 times all of this
business right over here which is the
exact same thing which is equal to 2
times our final frequency 2 times our
frequency final and or another way of
thinking about it her frequency final
her frequency final if I divide this and
this by 2 is going to be equal to 1/2 of
her frequency initial is going to be
equal to 1/2 of her initial frequency
frequency initial if your initial
frequency is twice your final then your
final is going to be 1/2 your initial I
could just divide both sides by 2 so
once again how does the frequency of her
spin change well it looks like her
frequency goes by 1/2 and that makes
sense if your angular velocity is going
down by half you're rotating half as
fast and so you're going to be able to
complete half as many cycles per second
so it makes sense that we are decreasing
our frequency is decreasing by a factor
of two it is having
decreasing by a factor of two is the
same thing as saying your frequency gets
multiplied by 1/2